la población en esta parte del noreste
de Ucrania especialmente en esta ciudad
de tiene razones reales para estar
preocupados como nos dicen dicen que en
las últimas semanas han venido haciendo
acopio de alimentos y de agua su
viviendas por si llegan a estar rodeados
y asediados como lo estuvieron ya al
comienzo de la invasión el año pasado
incluso otros dicen que tienen todo
listo para partir En caso de que haya
una nueva incursión Y estos temores
están fundados por los movimientos que
se han venido dando al otro lado de la
frontera en Bielorrusia en las últimas
meses y semanas Allí están estacionados
Diez mil hombres de las fuerzas rusas Y
actualmente hay ejercicios militares
entre los ejércitos de ambos países ayer
estaba mixtla capital Bielorrusia el
ministro de relaciones exteriores rusos
que se encontraba con el presidente
Alexander Lucas checo que decía que
había cumplido todo lo había prometido a
Rusia y ayer también hablaban ambos
ministros de defensa
instituciones que monitorean muy de
cerca la guerra especialmente al
instituto de estudios de la guerra con
sede en Washington había dicho hace
meses que podrían estar planeando una
nueva incursión a finales del invierno o
comienzos de la primavera que podría ser
lejana pero que existía sin embargo en
un informe publicado en el día de hoy
Dice que esto podría haber cambiado que
esta esta idea podría estar todavía
cuajándose pero no para estas semanas
cercanas sino para una vez llegado por
ejemplo el el otoño o a finales del
verano cuando ya toda la movilización en
Rusia se hubiera cumplido y también se
hayan coordinado malas estructuras entre
ambos ejércitos sin embargo esto no
oculta el temor que hay en esta zona del
país donde la gente se está preparando y
esos temores de lo que vivieron el año
pasado vuelven a revivirse